FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Wow.
So many accolades.
I'm so excited that you're
both here to talk with me.
First, I want to tell you all a
little bit about this cookbook,
where Dana consulted with
just a total who's who
of chefs that would
intimidate anybody else,
but this is in her wheelhouse.
Thomas Keller, for example,
wrote the foreword of the book.
She starts off by saying, "Good
cooking starts with honesty."
Around this statement, she
has a deep, dark secret
that inspired this
book, and I wondered
if you could tell
us a little bit
about your deep, dark
secret and how you
decided to bring this to light.
DANA COWIN: So the
dark secret was
that, after being
at "Food and Wine"
and talking about food all the
time and being on "Top Chef"
and knowing about food,
I never told anyone
that I actually didn't
know how to cook the food.
I could talk about it, but
I couldn't actually cook it.
That seemed like maybe
I should fix that
after 20 years at
the magazine, and so
this idea emerged that I
could actually learn myself,
but then I could share
with other people, which
was the book part, because
I feel like the really
dumb mistakes that I
make all the time--
and I really do make
them all the time,
and even after
having done the book,
I still make them in new
ways-- but those mistakes
that I make other people
make, too, so if I could
get the greatest
talents in the world
to tell me how to
fix the mistakes,
than I could spare an
entire universe of humans
from making the same mistakes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I want
to hear about the pseudonym
that you used to have and what
really pushed you over the edge
and brought you into the light.
It seems like mistakes
have been something
that you've learned
from all along,
but you really
wanted to go public.
DANA COWIN: I actually come from
a long line of mistake makers
and also a long
line of non-cooks.
My mother is actually the
original mistake maker
and original non-cook.
She would walk into an
immobile object in the street
and say, "excuse me," and
be looking for her glasses
and never find them.
In any case, they were
on the top of her head.
At the magazine, it didn't
seem like the wisest thing
to share with
people that I didn't
know how to cook
before I'd really
established my reputation.
So every weekend, I would cook
at home, come to the magazine,
and I would share
with the test kitchen
the mistakes I had made, and
they would try to help me,
and I decided it would be a good
column for the magazine, which
is what you're referring to.
And so under a
pseudonym, I did a column
where I made the mistakes
and our executive food editor
corrected them, and the
nickname Irma Rombauer
because, of course, she's one of
the greatest cooks of all time.
It was a little
inside joke with me
that I don't think
anybody else really got,
but I found it
quite entertaining.
That was a good,
solid 10 years ago,
but in the intervening 10
years, I became more confident
and I decided that
chefs like Jonathan,
if he found out that I
didn't know how to cook,
he would not think less of me.
And the readers, I decided,
they liked the magazine enough
that if they found that the
editor didn't know how to cook,
they would not think
less of the magazine.
And so I came to the conclusion
that it was OK to share.
And more than that,
I actually believe
in a philosophy of talking about
mistakes because if you don't
talk about them,
you can't fix them,
and if you don't fix
them, then you're
just sent into a life of mistake
making and not improving.
So I thought philosophically,
it was a good thing,
as well as for anyone I was
feeding, it was a good thing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So nobody was
surprised at these confessions?
DANA COWIN: No one
at the magazine
was surprised
because they'd lived
through every painful minute
with me, mostly Monday
mornings, but the world at large
actually was quite surprised.
I took calls from lots
and lots of people saying,
I don't believe you.
I was like, read the book,
because each of the head
notes for the recipes is about
the really stupid mistake
that I made and
then how I fixed it.
I failed in so many ways.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And what
was Jonathan's reaction
when you approached him
for his contribution?
DANA COWIN: Jonathan said, I'm
sure you're better than you
think, which was very nice.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Were
you just being nice?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: You know, I
have an incredible respect.
Listen, 20 years, Dana has
been editor of "Food and Wine"
magazine.
That's a huge
accomplishment, and when
she says I couldn't
cook, I think
she's really being a
little overly modest here.
And I think that
what she really is
saying that she wasn't an
accomplished chef or cook,
and that's what she's
really talking about.
The whole thing about
mistakes I think
is the key that binds
everything together
because I am the biggest
believer in mistakes as a tool
to get better.
In our society, we have
two ways of mistakes.
We could beat the
crap out of people
or we could encourage them,
and you could go either road.
I think when you encourage
people, then magic happens.
The other road is
the road to nowhere.
DANA COWIN: I will say that when
Jonathan and I were cooking,
we were in the studio together.
And the first thing I
did, I picked up the knife
and Jonathan was like, that's
not how you pick up a knife.
So though he says I didn't make
mistakes, my very first action,
he was like, that's
how you do it.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: No, I didn't
say you didn't make mistakes,
but you weren't an
accomplished cook.
DANA COWIN: I cooked a lot.
Let's say that.
So I picked up the knife
and he corrected me,
and then he looked in this pan.
We were making a
gravy, and he came in
after a number of the things
had been sauteed already.
And this was a recipe
that had already
been tested in the
kitchen at "Food and Wine"
and we felt very good about
it, and Jonathan was like,
do you have another set
of all those ingredients,
because I think we
could start again?
And we did it, and
it was fantastic.
I mean, you made
it so much better.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
it's a little bit
that Malcolm Gladwell thing
about you do it, in my case,
for 40 years, you
do the same recipe
but you change in such a finite
or infinitesimally small way,
but you get to a different
result, and a good day
and a bad day.
If it rains or it snows
or the sun is out,
your recipe is different.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So Dana
give a compliment to you
when she emailed
me the other day,
and she said that you're
one of the best people she'd
worked with as a
professional chef,
being able to teach these
skills to a home cook.
Was there a disconnect
for you, coming
from the realm of so much
expertise and experience,
trying to break it down to
an elemental thing for a home
cook?
Was there a challenge there?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I've actually
done a lot of teaching.
In fact, I started first
teaching back in 1979
with Wolfgang Puck.
He was a chef of a
restaurant called
Ma Maison, a famous
place in Beverly Hills,
and he started a
cooking school called
Ma Cuisine with the
wonderful Judy Gethers.
And they invited me to
be one of the teachers,
and I had no clue how to do it.
So I had Beverly Hills
housewives with giant rings
on their fingers, and that was
an amazing experience for me.
It really was.
In a lot of ways, it
taught me more about myself
than I really taught other
people, because I didn't
go to school to become a teacher
but I had to learn on the job,
so I had to fake it.
I had to fake the knowledge
that I could actually
teach people what I
did, but teach them
as a home cook versus a chef.
And I think there's
a big dichotomy here
because people say "cook"
and they say "chef,"
and there's a big difference.
There's a gigantic difference.
In fact, to be called
a chef, especially
in a place that reveres chefs,
like France or someplace else,
it's a whole different thing.
To become a chef is
really a hard road,
and a cook is a different game.
But I always think that I'd
rather eat in someone's home
with a great home cooked meal
than eat in a restaurant.
DANA COWIN: Always?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Always, always
because it's so much more
comfortable.
It's so much more relaxed.
DANA COWIN: But it's
only about the comfort?
It's not about the food?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: And the food.
There's nothing better.
Every summer, I go to France.
I go to this amazing
place in France
and the kids go to the
garden and they grab stuff
and they cook with me.
That's the greatest thing
in the world for me.
I'd rather do that
than anything.
DANA COWIN: Even than cooking
with me in the studio?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: That
was a lot of fun, Dana.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Tell us about
your process when you were.
You're on the spot being called
out for mistakes pretty much
from the get go.
What was the process
like, and how did you
hone in on the high yum
factor that you talk about?
DANA COWIN: Well, the
truth is we did start over.
We did have a second
set of ingredients
so that we could
begin the gravy again,
and the phenomenal thing
was that Jonathan showed me
that within-- was it
a 14 minute gravy?
Within 15 minutes, not
starting with the stock,
because among my
many mistakes, I
can never get a
chicken or a turkey
to yield enough juice
to make a gravy,
so I have to make
a juiceless gravy,
and that's what we
were making together.
But one of the reasons he's
such a great chef/cook/teacher
is that we started with these
ingredients and he just, very
slowly and gently, showed
how to get flavor out
of each one of
these ingredients.
It was bacon, of course.
He also started with
olive oil in the pan.
I'm like, but there's
bacon going into it.
There's fat in the bacon.
These things that I felt
like I had learned from chefs
all along the way, like
why would you start
with fat if you're adding fat?
He's like, don't worry.
It's really good.
And it was finished
with butter, so it
had three fats, which of course
is why it was so delicious.
So we cooked side by side.
I sort of poked at things
and Jonathan really cooked.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So you called
him the zen master of birds.
Was there anything that you
learned, aside from the recipe
and aside from what's in the
book, about just his mindset?
DANA COWIN: Well,
I think that one
of the great things
about Jonathan
is that-- I'm sorry to
say you take the easy way.
A lot of chefs, when I cooked
side by side with them,
they made whatever simple
thing I was doing so much more
complicated.
I wanted to roast vegetables
with April Bloomfield,
and I thought you would
chop the vegetables
and you'd put them on the tray,
and then you would roast them,
but that's not what a chef does.
A chef blanches them,
and then they saute them,
and then they put
them in the oven,
and then-- there's 10 steps, and
Jonathan exactly the opposite.
He took the idea of the
turkey, where people
have so many thoughts about
turkey, and I loved you said,
everyone from an expert
to your son has said,
you need to brine the turkey.
And he's like, no, you don't.
Nothing.
It's like, it's salt
and pepper here, people.
And I had an incredible problem
turning this gigantic bird
upside down.
I tore the skin.
It was a mess.
I had it on this large implement
so I could turn it over
and it was spinning.
It was not a pretty
sight, and Jonathan was
like, why are you doing that?
You just leave the
turkey sitting up.
That was great.
Also never tent.
He said, tents are
only for camping.
Why would you tent your bird?
Every single thing that
you thought you knew,
he had some incredibly
funny quip for.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
you know, listen.
You mentioned this whole
thing about California.
I was talking to
somebody the other day.
He said, I used to go horseback
riding in Napa Valley,
and the cowboys that would
wrangle the horses with us
used to cook.
They would take steaks and
they'd put mustard and salt
and throw them in the flames.
And I was 12 years
old and I go, what?
What are you guys doing?
And it was the most delicious
thing that I've ever
eaten in my life.
So it really stuck with
me that sometimes simpler
is always better.
It's not always better, but
it's served me pretty well.
It's not something that
I think is for everybody.
Some people like complicated.
Some people like
to do that 25 steps
to paradise kind of thing.
I think two steps to paradise.
I'm a little impatient, I guess.
I do this chicken at
Barbuto that everyone
wants to know how I do
it, and they're always
flabbergasted when I say
it's a good chicken and salt
and pepper.
And they say, well,
what else is there?
What's the magic?
And I said, the oven.
And then, of course, there
is one tool that you need,
which is a spoon, and you've
got to baste the chicken.
And they're, no, come on.
Tell me the real story.
You brine them.
You talk to them in Mandarin.
What do you do?
You inject them with soy.
You put truffle.
I said, no, you
don't do anything.
I think that people
just get so complicated.
That chicken is a
beautiful thing.
Why do you want to mess with it?
It's so gorgeous.
It needs a little salt,
needs a little pepper,
it needs some love, and
it needs to get basted.
DANA COWIN: It's all
about the basting.
I think it really is all about
the basting, though, right,
and that takes some patience.
When Jonathan told
me for the turkey,
I had to keep opening the
oven and basting this bird,
I'm like, do I really?
That's more than I want--
JONATHAN WAXMAN: It
was so much easier
than flipping that bird over.
DANA COWIN: I was going to
say I think I would actually
rather flip it than baste,
but he insisted on basting.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
there is something, Dana,
that people have to really
look into themselves.
People are scared of
ovens and the heat.
We all are because we don't
want to kill ourselves.
We don't want to die.
We get near them, we don't
want to burn ourselves.
We've all been burnt
by an oven, everybody
has, so once bitten, twice shy.
And I think that's
the fear factor,
as you become an
accomplished cook,
is to learn to love your oven.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Dana, did you
learn to love your oven yet?
DANA COWIN: My oven
doesn't love me.
Something that I learned
from so many of the chefs,
and particularly Thomas
Keller was talking about this.
The temperature in your oven
is probably not reflected
in your dial, I mean, assuming
that it's not an electric oven.
You actually never know what the
real temperature of your oven
is, so you need to get an
oven thermometer that's
really reliable.
So I have oven thermometers
but they're not reliable,
and then the oven, my back left
part of the oven is very hot
and the front right is
a 20 degree difference.
And then if you
open the oven door,
I think he said you
lose 20 degrees of heat
when you've opened
it and closed it.
So no, my oven does not love
me and I do not love it.
I actually do mostly
stovetop cooking.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Maybe
it's misunderstood.
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
But also, I think
people are afraid to saute.
The one thing when I was in
France and somebody said to me,
do you know what the
word "saute" meant?
I said, well yeah, to
fry something in a pan.
They said, no the word
"saute" means to jump.
And it was such a visually
important cue for me
to realize that sauteing was
not what I thought it was.
And so for young cooks
and people at home,
I always say that
you have to learn
the difference in pan cooking
and there's many nuances of it.
And those gradations
from simmering
to sauteing to braising,
all those different things,
are so important to what I
call the lexicon of cooking.
It's difficult sometimes
but people are, again,
afraid of flame.
That's why electric stovetops
have become so popular
because there's no flame.
I love electric stovetops.
You take a sponge, you wipe
them off, they're clean,
but they're also very
difficult to gauge temperature.
So to get precision-- and
I think of Thomas Keller,
who does owe me his life.
That's another story.
DANA COWIN: That's a good one.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: --is a
great master of precision.
And precision started
with pastry chefs.
Pastry chefs cannot live
unless they do it precisely.
My pastry chef does things.
It's 6 and 7/8 cups of flour.
I said, why not
just make it seven?
She gives me that look
like you're an idiot.
That's because
that's what it is,
because she knows that extra
scant one eighth of a cup
makes the magic happen.
So I think it's
confidence and learning
how to saute, learning
how to not flip
the turkey in the
oven, and then learn
the gradations of cooking,
and those are the fun things.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But is it
about precision necessarily?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I'm the least
precise cook that I know.
DANA COWIN: That must
be why I like you.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Because
I got in this business
after a being musician,
and when I was a musician,
the most important thing
in life was improvisation.
And I think that the key to
becoming a great cook or chef,
whatever you want to
call us, is learning
how to improvise,
but not improvise
so that you're playing "Stairway
to Heaven" as loud as you can.
It's learning how to
be subtle and beautiful
and respect the ingredients.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you tell
me more about the ingredients
piece, because I
feel like when you're
talking about the simplicity,
the quality of the ingredients
is just the key to all of that?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
I think that most people
think that food comes in a box.
You go to the supermarket and
it's in a box in a plastic bag.
I think with, thankfully,
what "Food and Wine" has
been doing lately,
and other magazines,
and other people the food world
are discovering the farmer.
And the farmer and the
fisherman and the people
that produce what we do are,
to me, the most important parts
of the whole puzzle.
I love this thing
about McDonald's saying
they're not going
to use antibiotics
in their antibiotic
laden chickens
anymore within the
next two years.
Why does it take them two years?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I don't want
to know the answer to that.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: We all
know the answer to that.
But I think that if we
respect those farmers
and we revere them more,
I think the world might
change a little bit.
I always think I'm a custodian
for what those people produce.
I grew up on a farm.
I hated being on the farm.
The smell was disgusting.
I hated fertilizer.
My grandmother used to
make me polish eggs.
Why do you polish an egg?
DANA COWIN: Why do
you polish an egg?
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
It's a long story.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Were you
in trouble, Jonathan?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I
was always in trouble.
You go the farmer's market and
you see that perfect zucchini,
it's like an emerald,
and an emerald
needs to be taken
care of and loved.
I always do this stupid thing.
Dana laughs at me.
I always think the
vegetables talk to me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But she
said that Alice Waters
was the vegetable whisperer.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well, she is.
Who did I learn from?
DANA COWIN: Jonathan
was right there.
Although I have a
totally new passion.
Did you hear about this?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: No.
DANA COWIN: So
Jonathan just outlined,
at the farmer's market,
the emerald zucchini,
and I'm going to
make a plea right
here for the dinged,
misshapen zucchini
because what's happened
with the farmers,
because not just people like
Jonathan, but because America
wants all of their
vegetables to be
straight and perfect
and of a certain size
and of a certain
color, there's 20% food
waste in just vegetables
and produce in America.
So these poor farmers that
we revere, both of us,
they toss it out because
they don't have the money
to have it trucked
away to someplace else
and they don't have the
time and the equipment
to turn that food
into something else,
because you could
make tomato sauce.
You could make minestrone.
There's things you could do.
But if you have
this gigantic farm.
So I'm now-- I just
launched this Saturday--
launching a campaign
called Love Ugly Food.
And it's an amazing thing
because if we can all
embrace ugly food, we could
actually help feed the world
and reduce food waste.
So I'm so glad you brought that
up because I love the emerald,
and it needs love,
but the unloved ones,
they need even more
love and they're going
to do even more for the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's revolutionary.
DANA COWIN: It is.
And I joined a movement.
It's like my eyes
just popped open
but there's a lot
of people who've
been working on food waste and
ugly vegetables for a really
long time, so credit to them.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's wonderful.
Bravo.
[APPLAUSE]
So on this
revolutionary theme, I
was really intrigued by
you talk about the personal
transformation beyond cooking,
beyond the kitchen, that
came out of creating this
book, and I thought maybe
that would be a good thing
to talk about to wrap up.
DANA COWIN: Great.
So I thought that I was
going to go in the kitchen
and learn to cook.
And as it turns out, my cooking
is still somewhat problematic,
but what I did learn, because
I had to codify my mistakes,
was that the thing
that I really lacked
was the ability to
focus, and that indeed,
if I could focus
and be completely
present in the kitchen and not
be thinking about something
I had to do for work or
be looking at my email
all the time or trying
to do 10 things at once,
I actually was a
far better cook.
And I'd be a much
better human being
because, in fact, that lesson
that you learn in the kitchen
was that you have
to be present, you
have to show love, which is
what you're talking about,
and you have to focus.
That's a much
bigger life lesson.
Sometimes maybe I don't
hold the knife right,
but the bigger thing was I ran
out of the room to do something
and that's when the
vegetables burned.
So staying focused was a
really important life skill,
and also honesty.
So those two things of admitting
that I was making mistakes
and saying I can get better
at this, because I'd never
really done that.
I made all the mistakes
and I ignored them.
I fed a lot of people,
no one was poisoned,
people were happy,
they were fun parties,
but I was never getting better.
So the honesty leading to
my life improving, and then
the focus, Those two things.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
And did you come away
with any big learnings?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
I love the whole process
because the whole
mistake thing, I think,
led to what
everybody's afraid of.
Most home cooks cook the
same thing all the time.
It's the comfort zone.
And I think part of my job is to
get people out of their comfort
zone, and when you
become uncomfortable
and you realize that you're
cooking the same thing
and people are getting
bored through the same dish
you made every time, that
if you all of a sudden break
open a cookbook
and find something.
I always say to people,
don't look at the cookbook.
Go to the market first and
shop and then come back
and find a recipe that
matches what you bought.
And then try
something new, I think
that is what we need as human
beings to really develop
because change is inevitable.
It can be good, it can be
bad, it can be otherwise,
but is inevitable.
When I started cooking, it
was all about French, Chinese,
and Italian food.
That was it.
And now the whole world
has come to our table,
and I think that's the
most amazing thing.
So you can have a little
bit of spices from India,
you could have a
technique from Portugal,
you could have vegetables grown.
It's a brave new world,
and I love that part of it.
DANA COWIN: Actually, is anyone
familiar with Dave Chang,
the Momofuku empire?
He has a restaurant called
Ko, which is a tasting menu,
and last night, he
did this agnolotti
that was stuffed with
a celery root puree.
So the celery root
puree was very French,
the agnolotti very Italian,
and then he had a curry sauce.
It was so brilliant.
I would never put
those things together.
He had shavings of fresh celery
and then scraps of truffle,
and a foam.
And I was like, this
is the whole new world.
The pasta was perfect and the
spice knocked your head around.
It's a very exciting time
to be eating and cooking.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's wonderful,
and I'm glad that lunch time is
almost here because now we're
all hungry.
So I thought we should leave a
little time for Q&A if people
want to ask questions.
We have two microphones on
either side of the room,
and I know that there's
some foodies in here
with some questions.
AUDIENCE: How do you think
celebrity has affected you
as a chef in both negative
and positive lights?
What have been the costs
and benefits of encountering
celebrity as a chef?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well, when I
was in a theater on 14th Street
with my son, I was
peeing at the urinal,
and a guy taps me on
the shoulder and goes,
you're Johnson Waxman.
My son looks at me with a
horrific look on his face,
so that's the bad side of it.
Somebody was talking
about because you're on TV
and the TV is in
everybody's room,
you become part of the
family, and I like that part.
And I always felt that I had
a responsibility to myself
to show myself in the light
of who I hopefully was,
but I had no clue who I
was going to be on TV.
That just happened, and I think
that's a crazy, weird thing.
But as far as the
rest of the world,
I think my industry
needs great people,
and if television can entice
wonderful individuals to want
to cook, that's a great thing.
But Bobby Flay worked
for me for five years.
I beat the crap out
of him all the time.
He was humble the whole time,
and look where he is now.
So I think that Bobby's base
was really being a cook.
His celebrity as
being a celebrity chef
is something different, but
they're really connected.
AUDIENCE: I was interested
at the beginning
to hear that both of
you have some background
with charitable works
that are related to food,
and since growing and
preparing and distributing food
is one of the most
nurturing things
that you can do, can you tell us
a little about how you decided
to give back and
what you're doing,
and perhaps ways that we
could contribute or find out
more about what you work on?
DANA COWIN: That's
an awesome question.
One of the really great things
about being involved in food
is there's so many
ways to give back.
I'm involved in
City Harvest, and we
have a Healthy
Neighborhoods initiative
that is extraordinary
that you can take part in.
You can go and help give
vegetables or sell vegetables
to those in need, and there's
others volunteer opportunities
at City Harvest.
And then at Hot Bread Kitchen,
which is a training program,
there aren't necessarily
actions that you
can take, like go make bread
with these amazing immigrant,
mostly women, but in
supporting their work
is extraordinary because
it helps change lives.
So it's not only
feeding people, but it's
helping train them to
have a better life.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just recently relocated from
San Francisco to New York.
I had to downsize significantly.
I live in West Village in
a shoebox, essentially.
You guys spoke about
home cooks experimenting.
That's something I'd love
to you as an avid cooker,
but I don't really have the
space to have a lot of tools
to experiment with.
So if I have an oven
and a drawer of storage,
what would you guys say are
the essentials that every home
cook should have
in their kitchen
if they are really limited
on space so they can still
experiment with food?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I
love that question.
Mary Sue Milliken
and Susan Feniger
had a restaurant in
LA many years ago,
I think 25, 30
years ago, and they
had a hot plate and a toaster
oven, and that was it.
DANA COWIN: I had one of
the magnificent failures.
I was cooking for my mentors,
the people who had given me
my start in magazines, so
two really big editors,
and I was making
dinner for them.
I took really good care of
the design of the table,
and I had chalkboards,
and it was cute,
but my stove wasn't
working because I
didn't plug it in
because I really
liked style more than design.
It was a '50s stove
that I had taken out
of a friend of mine's
grandmother's apartment.
It looked great.
I had a microwave, and I
tried to microwave poussin.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Bad idea.
DANA COWIN: That was bad.
I also had two hot plates,
and so I made pasta,
just going on the fly.
But you're going to tell
her she means a saute pan
and she needs a chef's knife.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: The thing
is you need one pan to saute,
you need one pot, you need
a little paring knife,
you need an eight inch
or ten inch chef's knife,
and you need what we call
a French fish spatula.
DANA COWIN: How
about a microplane?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: That
will save your life.
I do love microplanes
although I've
shaved my finger so many
times on those stupid things.
But the most
important thing is--
and I really believe
this-- that you actually
have a refrigerator.
Do you have a refrigerator?
AUDIENCE: I have a refrigerator.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: And is it cold?
AUDIENCE: It's very cold.
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
Then you're all set.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Question for Jonathan.
You mentioned that one
of your famous chickens,
that you baste but there's
a lot of other things
that you don't do that
are just unnecessary,
like you don't tent, you
don't brine and stuff.
Did you determine all of that
experimentally over many years?
How would one know,
as far as other dishes
go, that basting is the thing
to do but the other ones are
worthless?
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
Unfortunately, I
think there's going
to be a dead chicken's
head on my gravestone.
I feel sadly for
all those chickens
that I've cooked over the years.
But I think that what was
the most important thing
was I was talking with someone
about-- this sounds weird,
but subcutaneous fat.
What is that?
It's the fat underneath
the skin of the chicken.
So when you go to
the supermarket,
some of the chickens
look really pretty
but you've got to check out
what their fat content is,
and you look right around
the bottom of the chicken.
If they have good
fat content and you
see that beautiful fat content--
but it's hard these days
because they're in
plastic bags, but if you
go to a real butcher,
they'll show it to you.
Not all chickens are equal.
That's number one.
Number two is that
because I've grilled them,
I've roasted them, I've sauteed
them, I've poached them.
They're all great
ways of doing it,
but I found that-- this is
a little crazy-- at Barbuto,
we grill them and
then roast them.
DANA COWIN: See?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: But the
only reason we do that
is because we don't
have enough space
to do them all in the oven.
My restaurant
Adele's in Nashville,
we just roast them because
I have this beautiful wood
burning oven.
But it's really the basting.
I have a guy that's worked
for me for 15 years,
and he's the only one
that gets it perfectly.
I say, I want to do a video
and show-- his name is Luis.
He used to be a
dishwasher for me,
and now he's a
magician at the grill.
But when he does those
chickens, you watch him baste,
your mouth just drops open.
He does it three times.
He bastes it three
times and that's it.
DANA COWIN: But were
you asking in general?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Do you consider yourself an
experimentalist in cooking?
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
Oh, experimentalist.
I go back to the
improvisation thing.
My wife and I have a routine.
She goes to the farmer's
market and she shops.
I don't tell her what to buy.
She just buys
whatever she wants.
Then she leaves the kitchen.
And we have all the stuff
out, and then I make a mess
and she won't let me
clean up, and then
we sit down and
have a family meal.
And I love when I've got
everything around me,
looking at stuff, and
then you start thinking
about how to do things.
I make mistakes all the time.
I'll roast something off
and I'll taste it and I say,
this is terrible.
And then I have to figure
out either how to fix it
or you know where it goes.
And you have to have the ego to
tell yourself, this isn't good.
I remember when Alice Waters
went up to me and she said,
honey, did you
actually taste that?
I said, yeah, I did, Alice.
She says, did you
taste it every time?
No.
And she goes, that's your job.
Anyway, a long answer
to your question
is that I think I
do improvise, but I
don't think I go out of the
box like David Chang does.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here.
I had a question to you both.
Jonathan, you raised
a great point.
Home cooks tend
to get into ruts.
We don't experiment.
I definitely do that.
But one thing my husband
and I have been doing
is we've been using Blue Apron,
an ingredient delivery service,
and there's been definitely
a rise in the number
of those services.
I wondered what's your
perspective on them
as a magazine editor, and it's
all about providing people
with recipes, and a chef.
Do you think it's
cutting corners too much
or are you all about getting
people cooking any way
that we can?
DANA COWIN: I think Blue Apron
is a really, really great idea
because, indeed, you
get the ingredients,
you get the recipes,
and you can cook.
I'd rather have people
cooking than getting takeout,
and I think what would happen
is after enough Blue Apron,
you're like, actually,
I don't need them.
I'm going to go get a few
of these ingredients myself.
I feel emboldened,
I feel empowered,
and I feel joy when I cook
as opposed to fear or anxiety
or bored.
So I think you can
get so many ideas
and then you'll
take it on yourself,
and then if you don't
take it that far
and you're just doing Blue
Apron for the rest of your life,
that's really great, too.
I think it's good.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I think it's
a good stepping stone because I
think what you'll find is
that at one point you go,
this stuff's good but
if I did it myself,
I would do a better job.
And I think that's
the process that
happens because at one point,
you will be dissatisfied
with what you're getting.
It's good enough
for awhile, but you
know you'd rather go and pick
out your own little string
beans, the crazy
ones and the not so--
DANA COWIN: The bend.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: The bent ones
and the not so crazy ones.
DANA COWIN: And hit by hail.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: But I
think shopping is a joy.
We all love to shop.
And I think going to any food
place and taking the time,
it changes your life.
It gets you out of all
your craziness at work.
You go into whether it's Whole
Foods or the little bodega
on the corner,
your mood changes.
You have fun when you shop.
And I think whether you're
shopping for shoes or food,
it's a way to really change
our lives a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
By the way, I've cooked
from Dana's cookbook.
Everyone needs to try the
Nutella bread pudding.
It is a revelation
and quite easy.
It involves ice cream.
But I have a question.
You mentioned before
that you had two sets
so you could start
all over again,
and in a lot of instances, we
buy just enough for the recipe.
And inevitably, I've actually
cooked from your cookbook,
so I have made many mistakes
like burning pine nuts.
I didn't know how to
quarter something.
There was a lot of Googling.
So what do you do when
you've made a mistake?
Can you fix it, and
the recipe is not
going to tell you because
you can't anticipate it.
How often do you fix it?
I can't start all over again.
I've bought enough
ingredients from Fresh Direct
to get this one recipe done.
What you do to fix
versus start over?
DANA COWIN: I mean, it
depends how bad the fail was.
Those pine nuts, you
could just leave them out,
so I think some of that
you have to do on the fly.
As I said, for my lifetime of
making mistakes and cooking
and feeding people,
because I really only
cook for eight or more,
so most of the time,
people don't notice
the mistakes.
If you left out the pine nuts,
nobody's going to notice.
If burned a corner
of the chicken,
no one's going to
notice, and it's OK.
I think that that
was one of the things
that the chefs said to me.
I might be a little
over sensitive.
And then some things
are beyond redemption,
and then there's pasta.
AUDIENCE: There's pasta.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: One other
thing to think about, too,
is if you have your friends
come and taste for you
because you get too nervous.
You think you've failed
and you probably haven't.
You've probably just
made some silly mistakes
that are easily rectified.
And remember, putting everything
in one pot works all the time.
You know what?
Leftovers are the greatest
thing in the world.
You throw everything in the same
pot, you put it in a low oven,
and you go have a glass of wine
and come back and it's perfect.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I recently read an
article about that
the food labeling that indicates
the origin of where the meat
or fish came from is being
fought tooth and nail
by basically lobbying groups
that represent packagers
and all these things.
Unfortunately, we can't
go to the farm every time.
I try to go to the fish
market, but sometimes I
do have to buy at
the supermarket,
and personally,
I do want to know
where this produce came from.
What's your opinion on this?
Do you think that the food
should be clearly labeled
with the origin?
DANA COWIN: I think
the food should
be labeled where
it's from and what is
in it so we're not surprised.
Yes.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: You know,
I have this thing where
I do some mentoring of
elementary schools in New York,
and I went in and saw what
they were feeding my children.
I looked at the box, and
on the bottom of the box,
it was said made in China.
And I said, this is really bad.
This is not good.
But at least I knew
where it came from,
so I think labeling
this important.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
simplicity in cooking,
and I like simplicity
in cooking too.
So what's your
favorite food or recipe
with the least
amount of ingredients
where taking any of
those ingredients
away would completely
change the dish?
Well I do this
pasta dish, and it's
the dumbest thing in
the world, but it's
people's favorite thing to eat.
It's spaghetti,
but good spaghetti
that you spend a
lot of money on,
butter, a tiny bit of cream
and Parmesan cheese, that's it.
And there's nothing
better than it.
If you took one of
the ingredients away,
it wouldn't be the
same, but it's really
about the technique in cooking.
You've got to cook the pasta
perfectly, and you overcook it,
it's not so bad because
you just bake it.
You take the pasta
and you toss it
with the butter and the
cream and the Parmesan cheese
and you put it down.
If somebody were
blindfolded, that's
all they'd want to eat
the rest of their life.
DANA COWIN: I actually
just made lamb chops
that you pound so that
they're thin, salt, pepper,
hot, hot grill, two
minutes, two minutes.
It's three ingredients and
it's a ridiculous revelation.
You can't believe just
the pounding of it,
and then that high
heat so it's crusty,
and then it's a perfect
texture and it's a little salty
and you're done.
It's good.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming, guys.
So you guys talked about
David Chang a minute before.
I love going to a
David Chang restaurant.
It's a great experience
you get to taste things
you never got to taste before.
And yet, as someone
that loves cooking,
I inevitably prefer
going to Barbuto
because it inspires
me to do something
that I feel like I can do at
home because it seems more
simple, I guess, to use a word
that you guys have used before.
Dana, as an author,
as a magazine editor,
what's your opinion on
that in terms of how
you're talking to your readers?
DANA COWIN: I spend a
lot of time thinking
about what the threshold
is for our readers, what
is simple but interesting,
because we never
want to do something that is
so simple that it doesn't teach
you something new.
But the amazing thing is that,
both from the David Chang
side and the Jonathan Waxman
side, you can learn something.
So Dave, for
example, in my book,
we did kimchi pickles,
which are super simple.
It's like a gateway to Dave
but it's not the full on Dave.
And with Jonathan, the
ingredients are simple,
the technique is simple,
but you learn something
because you learn about basting.
As someone was saying, that's
the thing that turns it.
So we're always trying to give
the readers something that they
will want to do,
never to do recipes
that are way too complicated.
If something is going
to be very complicated,
we'll show a picture
that's inspiring
and then we'll maybe
pull out one part of it,
like a sauce or a
garnish or something
that you can do so you can get
that sense of a chef's identity
on your plate, but then you
serve it with a roast chicken
or something like that.
JONATHAN WAXMAN:
Remember the journey
hasn't been that long
for Americans and food.
It's really a new
journey for everybody.
When I started 40 years ago,
no one talked about food.
We only talked
about other things.
I think the journey is
just really beginning.
So I think David, on
the evolutionary track
of what you could do at
home, you just keep at it.
At one point, you go, I get it.
That's not that hard.
And really, it's a
little bit like you
want to go work on your car
and you go try to fix your car.
I did that once and it
was a complete disaster.
But I'd like to go back and
figure out how to do it,
and I think it's the same thing.
You've got to start simple
and you work your way
up the food chain.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
it's the same thing
but I get your point.
DANA COWIN: But also
someone like Dave.
He works all along
the continuum,
all the way from something
super, super simple.
He has a concept
that he's working
on that's between two
buns, and then he has Ko.
So I think a lot of chefs
work along the continuum,
and you can tap
into their thinking
anywhere along the
continuum, not just
at the really complicated end.
AUDIENCE: Building on that
question around David Chang
and the evolution of food, I'm
curious to hear your opinions
as to what you think are the
most interesting trends in food
today and who's
leading that revolution
and leading those changes.
DANA COWIN: Well, since
my obsession at the moment
is-- and it will be ongoing, it
won't be fleeting-- food waste,
to Dan Barber from Blue Hill
Stone Barns, if you know him,
and he also has Blue
Hill in Manhattan.
This month, he's doing a pop
up called Waste Ed-- wasted--
but it's about educating
people about food waste,
and I think chefs all
around the country
and all around the world
are tackling this idea.
So Dan has chefs
coming literally
from all over the world
to cook with ingredients
that we would have thrown
out, and I think that there's
a very interesting
movement with chefs taking
on these really big topics.
At the same time, as
I'm sure you all know,
the notion of vegan has
gone from "eew" to "ah,"
and that's been
a beautiful thing
to watch as so many
chefs experiment
and come up with dishes that
are really delicious that
use whole foods.
Whole grains is
a gigantic trend.
It used to be that you
thought if you were eating
whole wheat you were
doing a good thing,
and now Marco Canora
has a fantastic new book
on whole grains and
whole grain cooking,
partly in response to
the gluten free movement.
So I think there's
a lot of interest,
if you bucketed it together,
in experimenting with new ways
to eat for health, where
the flavor is delicious.
Fermentation.
I mean, Jonathan's
a great old hippie.
Everything that the hippies
did, it's totally new again.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I actually
wasn't a hippie, but that's OK.
DANA COWIN: Are you sure?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Yeah, I'm sure.
But continuing, I think it's so
important what Dana just said.
I think that doctors were
completely oblivious to what
nutrition was about
and now doctors
are waking up to
what can cure us
and how food can really
replace the drugs
that they shoved down our
throats because the drugs we
take are just panaceas.
They're just there
to placate us.
And this whole thing
about Alzheimer's.
Why is there so much
Alzheimer's happening?
gluten allergies?
It's just expanding
exponentially,
and I think what doctors
really need to understand
is food as a core subject.
You look at different cultures,
and cultures that are healthy
versus cultures that are not
healthy, and what do they eat?
How do they eat?
What are their diets like?
Who knew that kale
and collard greens
were the best things you could
possibly eat in your life?
And then we said,
well, you're not
supposed to eat fat because
of all the cholesterol
and everything else.
Well, your brain is 75%
fat, so maybe there's
a correlation between
what our brain is made of
and what we eat, and now doctors
are waking up to that fact.
The more research they do, and
the more correlation, the more
they talk about the
stuff and they figure out
that what we cooked at
home from the field,
and how we cooked it, and
we didn't use GMO products.
We just got basic stuff from
the farm and we cooked it well,
and we lived
healthy lives, maybe
there's something to all that.
I think that really is the
most fascinating thing for me.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
how do you pick up a knife?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Well,
that's a really funny thing.
I was a trombone player, and
how you pick up a trombone?
There's a wrong way
and a right way.
It goes back to
if I gave a knife
to Dana, how do
I hand it to her?
Do I stick the
knife towards her?
That's bad.
AUDIENCE: How much
do you like her?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: Do I turn
the knife around and hand her
the handle?
I'm going to hold the handle.
There's a proper way to do that
and we learned it in school.
So you put your three fingers
under the bottom of the handle,
you take your thumb.
There's the bolster
that's on every blade.
Put your thumb one side of the
bolster and your index finger
on the other side of the
bolster and you turn.
Here you go.
There you go, Dana.
There you go.
And she grabs it the
same way, and that's
how you hold a knife.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Shall we say
this is our last question?
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I have two quick
ones, hopefully.
Maybe they're related.
So one is around
portion control.
I'm wondering if you have
any quick tips or advice
for when you have guests
over and when you're serving,
and also just when
you're eating yourself.
Do you eat certain things
first so that you get more full
in the beginning, or what looks
good in portions on plates?
I'm just curious about that.
And then lastly, secondly, I
tend to travel a lot for work,
and I'm curious.
We're really privileged to be
in New York and other areas
that I tend to travel that
are very foodie towns,
and I can benefit from
that when I'm traveling,
but some places I go are not.
Most of the country is not.
And so do you have
recommendations
for folks who are
on the road and all
you get is the room
service in the hotel
or around the town,
which is really far
from optimal and ideal?
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I was talking
to Phil Lesh from the Grateful
Dead last year,
and his wife used
to bring a saute pan and
go to the market and make
scrambled eggs for him at
2 o'clock in the morning
because he couldn't find a place
to eat, so I know your trouble,
but you've got Google.
I'm sorry, but it's the
greatest thing in the world,
the greatest tool.
If I'm in a foreign
city and I don't
want to have room
service because I know
they're going to burn
one half of the club
sandwich and the other
part's going to be cold,
and I don't want to have that
at 2 o'clock in the morning.
So I just Google where I'm at.
And all these rating things
now, if you look at them all
and then you use your
power of intuition,
you go, that place looks really
cool, or you do barbecue.
I want to eat barbecue tonight.
I think the world is very
changed in that respect.
And you've got to be
willing to take the risk.
And it could be
bad, but why not?
Why not try it?
I think that we're getting more
bold with our choices of places
to eat.
DANA COWIN: I have a fear,
which is a ridiculous, unfounded
fear, of being in a
place and not having food
that I want to eat, and so my
bag-- today, I have an apple
even though I'm coming
here and there's
nothing but food in this entire
building, from what I can tell,
but it's free.
I had to have an apple
and I had to have
a healthy granola rather than
an overly sweetened granola,
so I pack.
I went to Asia and I
brought food with me.
I like having some
control and I don't
want to be starving and then
eat something disgusting, which
is the greatest thing
I like to avoid.
Sometimes I'll go into a market
and buy healthy, whole foods
that would make me happy
through a day, which
would be dried
fruits, nuts, things
that are filling and
sustaining, good for your brain.
And then I tend, in
situations that you're in,
to go for something
that I know is real.
So usually, you can
get an egg, and I
feel like an egg
is usually real,
except sometimes they come in
the-- what are those things?
Egg replacements.
They come in big vats,
pre-scrambled eggs.
Anyway, you wouldn't know.
But a fried egg in the
morning, it's very reliable.
And then I try to stay
away from the things that
are going to be very empty
calories because they're just
going to make me feel bad.
So I try to stay away from
the pastas and the breads
and the bagels, which are
all very readily available,
but they're not going to
make me feel very good.
Portion control.
I also have a little
paranoia around portions
because when I entertain,
I do eight different bowls
of things, all room
temperature so that I
have to prep them
early in the day
so that if I make a
mistake, I can fix it.
One thing is grains, one
that's a leafy vegetable, one
that's a roasted vegetable.
So I always allow people to
choose the food for themselves
because that way,
they can figure out
how much they want to take,
and I always make way too much,
but then there's leftovers
and I'm good with that.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: I was
very privileged to know
Danny Kaye when I was
at Michael's restaurant,
and he invited me to his house.
He was a famous cook,
and he just loved life.
I walked into his house.
He says, Jonathan, it's
all about the preparation.
He showed me in
front of his wok,
because cooked
lots of Asian food,
all these little bowls
perfectly portioned out.
He never portioned them.
He has five people in the
back doing all the chipping
and chopping.
But it was such a revelation
to see everything ready to go
and you relax and you can cook.
So if you can do those
things in advance,
and you can do it a day in
advance or two days in advance.
Nothing goes really
that bad, trust me,
especially if the refrigerator
is cold-- 39 degrees,
by the way.
You've got to be 39 degrees.
That's a whole other subject.
Anyway, if you have all
those things portioned out
and you start cooking, you
can have a glass of wine
and have fun.
AUDIENCE: Seems like
a recurring theme.
DANA COWIN: Is it the
glass of wine or the fun?
AUDIENCE: The food, I
guess, also is a topic.
Thank you.
JONATHAN WAXMAN: You're welcome.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
Well, that was a great
round of questions.
Thank you both
for your insights,
and I want everybody
to join me in thanking
Dana Cowin and Jonathan Waxman
for joining us at Google today.
[APPLAUSE]